welcome to this video this is a new part
of endgame basics and theory this is
about bishop against bishop with one
extra pawn for one side yeah we normally
look at it from the white side as it is
done in those theoretical discussions so
white has an extra pawn with one Bishop
each of the same color let's look at
some typical positions way to waste who
were to win this in certain situations
ways to defend you start with the the
simplest position of of all the the
simplest draw for the defender here
black this is of course a total draw
where you are standing in front of the
pawn you're on the other color then the
new bishop like here on a dark square
and black is just shuffling is bishop
forever and can can never lose actually
you just stay on his seven and and wait
and wait and wait and never ever can
lose very em very simple to understand
it gets more complicated of course if
you are not getting in front of the pawn
which very often will happen let's look
at a typical situation where you are not
in front of the pawn as the defender
this is a typical situation the D pawn
now is far advanced very close to
promotion and the only thing that stops
white from winning is of course the
black bishop ready to sacrifice itself
in case the pawn really pushes to the
7ya the winning idea here is of course
quite simple you need to make sure that
the bishop cannot sacrifice and white
needs to offer a bishop trade to fight
for the key square on d7 note that and
this is a key point
Black's King is not in front of the
prominent as mentioned right away but
it's also rather far away from from this
pawn it takes a number of moves to
actually even get near the pawn that's a
very important thing
oops not
cannot jump 287 yeah so how does white
procedure this is a win
yeah this is a win and the easiest
witness with Bishop f3 this is a very
clear-cut way to win intending to play
Bishop c6 the key the key square
actually him to get the bishop to black
am now has no way to to avoid that it is
some important to see that after let's
say Bishop a form Bishop c6 yeah if the
bishop now moves away we are just
playing d7 after this we win the King
opponent game like go so let's say here
Bishop c6 this is no difference
whatsoever if black tries to do this
King eight yeah can I have a look at
this again and again if you win the King
and pawn endgame yeah this is a case
where white has a clear-cut winner
because this is basically the worst
possible scenario for black yeah you're
very close to promotion you don't have
the king is black in some sort of
defensive role it's basically the same
thing
the king is here on g1 there let's say
it's a it's not really measuring very
much the king is not doing anything
there is in fact a scenario where blacks
King being more active makes all the
difference
let's look at the scenario now here this
is a quite similar position but a big
difference the king is on c5 it is in
the rear of the pawn in opposition to
White's King if you if you want and what
it does is it always also texts upon the
King here is really playing an active
role and very importantly it also has a
look at
six square which as we have seen before
is a key square for the white bishop to
to go to trying to yeah for the for the
trade-off bishops in this case here
white cannot win this is a total draw
yeah let's look at let's look at some
ideas what can white try to do yeah he
can try to play em this and of course
we're not trading yeah this is a big
mistake we're just going away with the
bishop because Bishop e7 has blocked the
pawn white cannot advance it at the
moment okay he can go here threatening
this and we switch back to this diagonal
again covering the d7 square how it's
white I'm going to to make any progress
very difficult if we if he stays here we
just keep watching the d7 square there's
simply nothing possible to do also note
that this attack make sure that the
white king is never moving yeah there's
really no no way forward
um yeah white can again go here if you
want yeah you got back time to and it's
um it's a very very simple draw like
it's just always observing d7 and has no
problem in doing so and the other
situation the king was just far away and
there also was this e6 Square to to
fight them to fight for them
for the advance of the pawn this is a
clear draw the King behind the pawn in
in in opposition however this is not
always a draw it is a draw here but it
can be lost anyway if one of the
diagonals is too short we are coming to
this situation now yeah this is a
of the first position but it is shifted
towards the queenside the difference is
that now if we look at them diagonals
involved we see that those diagonals
include one that is very short yeah the
this three square long diagonal and in
case of the one diagonal being shorter
than four square so three three squares
and dance
it is normally a win yeah there are
borderline cases but this is normally a
win why exactly we have a look at the
typical procedure how wide wins in this
position white to move Bishop c8 for
some reason I need to switch try to move
Bishop c8 is them the first move we want
to go to the long diagonal that makes
lots of sense Bishop before this should
be seven Bishop d3 yeah you have to go
away from the long diagonal if instead
black goes to f5 you play here the
bishop has to go to c8 otherwise we may
push the ship c8 and Bishop d2 and now
we come to a supine position this is the
problem in this concrete situation there
is simply no yeah if there was would be
you let's say yeah a square near the
king yeah yeah like on the fifth rank
something left to the a file then you
could go to be fire - 2 to the 5th rank
we cannot the board is simply ending
here cannot go one more and there is no
square yeah like is in Zeus one if you
play something like this we have Bishop
a6 and moving the bishop obviously
announced the advance of the pawn
if you go to d3 the procedure is some
quite similar
Bishop f3 bishop a6 Bishop g4 and again
zooks mom this is too short
yeah there is no square like like d9 or
something like that and black now is in
suits funny yeah I'm moving the bishop
somewhere somewhere here a nice
promotion moving the King it's not
exactly helpful so this is a suits funny
yeah very important to remember if one
of the diagonals is shorter than four
squares then the chances of winning
crease considerably almost all positions
are one there are some freakish cases
where this is not the case but very very
very very tricky a situation so that
must be ok let's look at the further
example this is a version of the last
position now it's an F pawn not yeah G
of B pawn
look at this there's a check white needs
to move the King and it's a rather
logical case here where to move the King
there is only one move that wins this is
King g8 is very important it's about the
short diagonal this short tang and all
the King needs to control as many
squares as possible of this diagonal
after king JT wins quite easily let's
say king g6
Bishop f8 and we see that this will win
rather rather simply it's a it's very
comparable to the situation before
possible - especially f8 move let's say
Bishop f4 to be ready to go here we go
away Bishop h6 and Bishop b2 we come to
the long diagonal and we see that those
squares are control
and if the King moves now we come here
and actually oops promote our pond King
g8 is a very simple win actually however
if white is ignoring that and goes to
yet it is a draw King e6 of course we
adopting this rear opposition as we have
seen before this is the best the best
year defense yeah right now can try it
but he cannot win anymore
Bishop f8 Bishop f4 we should be fine
Bishop h6 note that the skin is far less
effective because it is not controlling
those vital squares the g7 square very
important here's the key square with the
King on g8 not possible
yeah and there is really no way forward
black is holding his control over a fade
yeah so it's very important in those
cases where the diagonal is too short it
is only too short if Bishop and King
work together on on those squares of the
upside of the short diagonal those
squares okay now look at now we look at
a different a different scenario we had
the pawn is not as far advanced yeah
this is a scenario where the point is
just on the fifth rank which of course
is helpful for the defendants the more
backward the pawn is the easier the
defense how should black play here to
draw there is a very clear-cut way to
draw whichever was not played in this
actual position courage Iike Markland
again from the 70s the easiest draw here
not the only draw but the easiest
drawing here is in fact not to try to go
in front of the pawn because you won't
manage that easily but to go to this
real opposition team d5 is the best way
to do it
King g6 TV for and we are aiming to the
real opposition bishops at 7
our King a 358 King g4 and this is
exactly where we want to be we have this
pawn under attack so the White King
cannot advance and we are controlling
the key square he on f6 there is really
no way forward for right
you can always control this square note
that in this case the diagonals are
really no yeah that's a much easier
affair look at this diagonal then with
the pawn on the same rank
White has absolutely no way to progress
in this position
however black didn't do that once it's
also not that intuitive if you don't
know the method
you probably automatically try to run in
front of the pawn to stop it yeah he
went King be seven in the game kingi six
plan yet yeah this was was his idea
Bishop f4 intending to go to h6 yeah
how can black defend here there are some
only one defense left still and this is
to go to g8 exactly and now in that this
is in fact still drawn due to the fact
that the pawn is still on f5 it is only
working due to this and due to this fact
White has no way forward we can again
check a couple of ways to try it for
example like this yeah king opponent
game we lose but there is some no reason
to take we can just stay and ask white
okay you're on this diagonal now you're
not pushing your paw no are you so he
will do something like this bishop h4
again looking at this the diagonal
assesses it's long enough
I know no problem whatsoever and white
will absolutely not make any progress
note that if we come to this situation
and white tries to offer in exchange
here we can of course straight because
we get to the key squares of the F part
white is not coming in front of the
so it's a draw only a draw because the
pawn is that far back on f5 so this is
the frontal let's say defense against
the pawn in cases where it is not yet
advanced that farm mostly the backward
of back defense from the rear yeah
this is rightward the defense from the
rear is the cleanest way to do it black
said earlier this kind of way is the
easiest way to do it okay we have seen a
number of very typical themes now let's
maybe look at one final position that
helps us to to see the points of this
endgame again yeah let us look at this
position and yeah sum up some points
about it yeah we have a deep pond which
in general is one of the may be lesser
dangerous ponds because of the diagonals
being the involving the angles being
rather long yeah let's say a B or G porn
is a bit more dangerous on the negative
side blacks defending King is not in a
great position it would rather be here
of course to attack it from the rear
speed learned that this is a good thing
so is this a draw
yeah it's still at wrong but blacken
needs to be very very precise and know
what is doing let's have a look at some
some some ideas it is White's tunics and
of course why to move because black to
move is easy you just go to the 8th and
to DNA draw so why does playing Bishop
h5 the only possible way to try to win
this push up a tree we need to stay on
this diagonal what else
yeah and now what are possible trials
for why to win the most dangerous tribe
is kingi 5 ke 5 tries to reach the
position that we looked at
first in this video the king is here
trying to walk over to this square the
other possible idea that we should look
at and let's do this first is Bishop to
g6
note that ideas to force a trade on f5
black has a defense however we should be
7 that's very important you can just
drop back and the point is that after
Bishop f5 we have the good move King yet
and this actually secures an immediate
draw we get to d8 or we get to a drawn
King opponent game that's a very
important defensive motif and the only
one that draws really reliably and
easily but as mentioned the most
interesting tribe is King to e5
what has blacks best defense here
knowing the defensive technique of the
attack from the rear
it is pretty easy to determine actually
the best defense here is king to g7 it's
maybe counter to it if you don't know
the the idea but if you know it it's
pretty easy to employ now black is just
coming around and basically yeah sort of
pursuing the the white king something
like that let's say and we are in the
rear of the pawn you just get them in
time and draw it is really something -
yeah rather do immediately and not
hesitate to long if black plays a tempo
losing moves that's not doing much and
here you're really forced to go King g7
if you're not doing it now you're too
late if you now go King g7 and you
really have lost the complete move you
still draw you're just you're just about
in time but really just about here and
you're just controlling this square but
by one move if you go to g7 one move
earlier it is a bit more bit more
convenient let's still see what happens
if black is not knowing the defensive
technique if he plays a move like that
here he will lose his just too late King
c5 we should be seven King b6 something
like that and we arrive at the winning
position that was shown at the start of
the video white will win by using this
this square finally at c6 to push the
pawn home so it's um yeah a typical
thing in Chettiar you need all your
pieces working to have a good good
position and a good defense and in this
case it is the black King that needs to
yea come to this rear defense yeah this
situation but you help by attacking the
pawn and controlling the importance is
six square to draw yeah so I hope that
some a video will help you in yes
securing a couple of five points or yeah
maybe sometimes win with them with the
extra pawn in this time of endgame it
happens quite often and it's very useful
to know this defensive method with the
King behind the pawn it's not a very
intuitive one this is why it's so useful
to know note that this is of course as
an endgame this Bishop and
one against Bishop with same colored
bishops this is of course an endgame
that a computer with table bases even
with our table bases will play
absolutely perfectly if you want to
practice this just put up some positions
against the chess engine on your
computer there's some online resources
as well and then just just practice yeah
and see what happens just shuffle around
a bit and see how the computer evaluates
the various positions and compare
positions or enter some positions from
this video into into into the computer
and play against that see if you can win
the one positions draw the drawn
positions and the sort of play around a
bit what happens if you switch a pawn
from the D file to the C file to the B
file whatever this is very helpful in
learning the ins and outs of the endgame
the goal really should be to come to a
situation where you make most of those
moves automatically without without
thinking yeah I hope you enjoyed this
this was a very good point to start with
Bishop end games something that
definitely will be addressed later in
this series I'll step-by-step go through
all the endgame types with simple
situations next one will be Knight and
pawn against a single night and then we
come to the more complex ones especially
rook end games of course with rook and
pawn where this ruckus is really really
complex and has lots of subtleties that
you're yeah hardly aware of if you just
look at it briefly yeah okay I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching